let's ju let's jump over to uh wokeness
and media we have this uh tweet from
nathan grayson over the washington post
who says he is a video game reporter i
suppose that means that he will provide
us information reporting on video games
oh however he tweeted and before i
before i get into it nathan buddy you
made it congratulations here's what you
were hoping for
you are now getting talked about he says
shannon liao and i reached out to over
20 major video game companies about
whether they intend to speak up in favor
of reproductive rights or provide
monetary aid to employees just a few
said yes most said nothing at all
this is literally the wendy's meme
this is
this is a wendy's sir yeah it's like
this
bro i i just i would love to see this
guy like pull up to a wendy's and
they're like i'm gonna land and i thank
your order do you support reproductive
rights sir this is a wendy's i'll take
that as a no can you write it down
they're not that far from that point
we're going to see articles from
journalists like i went to the wendy's
on 2nd street and they would not give a
strong stance in favor of reproductive
rights we should legit do this
let's go to wendy's
just for the purpose of being like do
you support women's reproductive rights
and the guy's going to be like i'm 16
and i just make cheeseburgers like
excuse me how does super mario feel
about roe v wade being overturned he
actually includes that comment in there
so he has this big twitter thread
and it's fascinating too let me say
something on the culture wars
this guy
likes the fact that we're talking about
it he doesn't care about us he doesn't
care that he's not reporting this is the
future of what these media companies
will be the washington post has become
kotaku this you know just just gamer
gate leftist woke media and it works for
them and they're going to get the people
who care about the people who don't like
right-wingers or whatever and so he
doesn't care what we say about him like
do you think i care when they write
about me or whatever i ignore all of it
i don't care like people are chatting
and smack talking me and i'm like i can
only read so much this guy doesn't care
he's getting attention it's working for
him and this is what the culture wars
become
so he goes on to mention that bungie
says they're for it blah blah blah and
then he starts talking about people are
suddenly losing their minds over this
piece so let me spell out the rationale
behind it game companies were extremely
vocal following george floyd's murder
covet-borne anti-asian hate silence here
is telling it suggests broader
disingenuousness i'm sorry
i like started laughing while i was
drinking what a ridiculous thing like
is it firstly to want these companies to
comment on in the first place but but
secondary like does he think that these
companies just became right-wing yes
they started becoming conservative like
well look this is one where we really
are more conservative he he quote
tweeted ben shapiro who said in which
activists masquerading as journalists
call up companies and ask why taylor
swift's silence is so definite he says
lol lol that's he likes it
he says if fox decides to do a segment
on me my one request is that they use
this picture
and this is the point this guy's not a
reporter he is an activist his reporting
makes literally no sense i mean it's the
wendy's meme am i gonna am i gonna say
well wendy's once had an lgbtq twitter
icon they have not said anything about
abortion it's deafening
like one day they everybody all the
companies were putting their uh profile
pictures black for like after george
floyd and then if a company wouldn't do
that everybody lost their minds but i
feel like it's the same thing as as
taylor lorenz is bad uh
sort of like bad intention disguised as
journalism where she was like oh uh the
reason why i had to expose the lives of
tick tock girl is because she could have
been a russian asset okay well you found
out she wasn't a russian asset and you
still expose her so it's like oh uh the
reason why i'm doing this with the video
games is because they did that and so
they're always gonna find an excuse to
their bad journalism or activism or
whatever but it's like
shut up
already i mean
sure sonic the hedgehog isn't a russian
you can't be sure so if you look just to
the right on twitter you have gaming
trending blizzard announces kings
diversity space tool a measurement
device to help identify how diverse a
set of character traits are which is
planned to be released internally
starting the summer here's what's gonna
happen oh gosh it is meme come to life
the next triple a game that comes out
every character is gonna be a trans
disabled no
furry please no no yeah that's gonna
happen i noticed a person of color new
games where they uh
where they were it said when you pick
your gender instead of man or woman now
you can pick like type one type two
other things in elven ring it says like
type a type b or something like type one
type two like you're choosing your
character's form of diabetes no no i
thought this was funny i called them
sexist i tweeted about i was like you
know eldon ring is sexist because the
female body type is number two
what it should have been type one and
type a seriously female i mean it's
called male or female woman you have man
or woman like why do you think it's a
secondary why do i have to add on extra
letters to describe it that reminds me
of that uh jk
rowling um
stuff where she was always like nobody
asked her anything and she was like
dumbledore was gay
that was gay yeah that's that mean so
why why do i care that if sonic is
having something with tails like
stop it i don't i don't want to see it i
don't want to think about it so ian i
will give you a uh a linguistic lesson
thank you woman comes from whitman the
original uh i think it's old english i'm
not sure and it used to be males were
wormen and so there were two distinct
words women and whitman and then due to
i think what they said was
the the the work role being masculine
men just started saying men instead of
women because if they would say man in
reference to a human being in general
but only men were around men just
eventually became the default for male
or whatever the other night i was
thinking i think the word woman needs a
new word because it women may have
birthing process no it's something yeah
simple one syllable like a leader there
you go something
something that can compete with
it like an extra aberration of the word
man like menstrual blah man you know
just like a new word that sounds cool
sounds metal you know it's crazy flip
flip yeah you're on youtube in the right
space
the this oh i see it everywhere like um
so i'm originally from brazil i lived
there for 20 years of my life so
whenever people say
uh latinx
it
like it it hurts me a little bit i get i
get the i get the eye twitch
because yeah in in
uh latin languages
the male version is also the i guess
unisex version of a word so whenever
you're referring to somebody that you
don't necessarily know their gender
you would use the male form so
it it
it hurts me
i'm sorry well i i understand that as a
flip you may be more confident exactly
well and this is it's not is it like
what did the did the left go into the
latino community ask do you guys want a
new name no they just decided to name
them because they think they have
ownership over the entire group of
people because that's what renaming
someone or something means it means you
own them and they see them as political
pawns not as human beings and their
political pawns who belong to them in
their estimation so that's why they get
to decide what they're called this is
why everyone has to resist the term
this is why i said uh like it was a year
a year ago that the gender-neutral uh
pronoun for everyone is fluorbo i like
that yeah it's soft it reminds me of
flubber with that robin williams you
know it was fun childhood memories
nobody can complain about that there's
an o at the end that's too masculine
yeah it's too masculine
it's i was looking up non-binary in
spanish and it's nobinaria and nobinario
yes
there's a binary way to say no
non-binary of course i like that
ironic
it's insane i wish they would stop that
but they don't so it's like we already
have a word for that we already have a
way of saying it why why don't you just
ask us instead of pushing it like who
came up with this well they they did
they they conducted studies and they
asked people they're like do you like
the term latinx
latin women
what makes it well they should ask women
what they think of the word website
because everyone hates it no one's going
to use it nobody asked me any any
exactly like
this uh polls and stuff like that
everybody's like oh somebody nobody
asked me nobody ever called me and asked
me
do you do you want this dude like it's
i've never been asked about a poll
listen you you need to understand that
the um
being
a morbidly obese millennial woman with
pink hair inside of your head shaved
grants you a kind of
intelligence that you just know what's
what's better for
the oppressed people it's the color of
the hair it makes kids want to listen to
them because they like bright colors
brainwashing it is it is it is crazy how
you see this stuff in schools where it's
like they're like what gender are you
and cisgender is black and white
and then it's like you know trans is a
bunch of colors and it's like pride and
rainbows and they're like if that if if
you want to be fine if you want to be
the boring black and white color
fine by the way i want to bring
something really fun up here uh that
validates everything we're saying so
fantastic but according to pew research
76 percent of latinos surveyed had never
heard the term latinx uh of those who
heard it in in totality so of of the 100
percent of people who were asked if they
had heard the term only three percent
said that they used it 20 said they knew
it and didn't use it 76 percent said
they never heard did did they break it
down between men and flibs uh i can
double check
i can double check on that
but it doesn't appear so i believe they
did break it down a little bit maybe in
another poll where it showed that
college-educated women were the only
group that liked it and they used it and
i was like this is in no way surprising
i heard college educated flips yeah oh
you're right well flip is worth living
you gotta be careful but we'll figure it
out yeah
i heard latin
calm down
i love that or what is it latinx or
latinx who knows we want to know about
this pink sound sounds weird like
it inks like i don't like
that's what i thought like it reminds me
of like
tinkle so yeah tinkle this latino tinker
licks um i heard if people if people
want if people demand you give them a
special name that they demand to be
called
like just make up one that doesn't sound
good yeah in fact i won't use the one
that offends you but i'll i'll i'll
choose one for you
i'm so glad first the first amendment is
free speech because people make up words
and they want me to start using their
lexicon it's i feel so bad for the
canadians man that bill c-16 and then i
think other bills have been passed that
is like forcing people to use certain
words so they don't offend other people
you ready for this you don't hold on
not yet but you can change my mind
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 p.m
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there
you